[Musique]
c'est une décision qui est loin de
passer inaperçue celle de karl olive
maire divers droite de poissy dans les
yvelines qui a décidé de prendre une
décision radicale pour lutter contre la
délinquance dans sa ville à poissy dans
les yvelines la ville supprime des aides
pour les familles de délinquants plutôt
que d'attaquer les délinquants mineurs
sur leur terrain le maire a décidé de
s'en prendre au porte-monnaie de leurs
parents ainsi hier a été voté en conseil
municipal à 36 voix sur 39
la suppression de certaines aides en cas
de non respect de la loi le maire tient
ainsi à viser les délinquants de 12 à 17
ans qui sont particulièrement virulents
ces derniers mois si certains sont
d'accord avec la décision du maire un
maire est pleinement habilités à faire
ce genre de travail
d'autres s'insurgent que des parents
parfois impuissants face aux dérives de
leurs enfants soient sanctionnés à leur
place je pense que c'est totalement
injuste ce genre de mesures
alors faut-il sanctionner les familles
de délinquants karl olive le maire de
poissy et ce soir avec nous pour
défendre son point de vue
karl olive merci d'être avec nous je
sais que de nombreux plateaux télé
voulez vous avoir ce soir pour
comprendre voilà cette mesure et c'est
vrai que ça à diviser toute la journée
sur les réseaux sociaux
vous étiez en top tweets voilà c'était
toute la journée ou parler que de vous
est ce que vous comprenez faut-il
sanctionner des familles de délinquants
je vois qu'ici tu vois ta mais vous
pouvez le voir un karl voilà c'est assez
c'était plus d'ailleurs oui que non on
va voir ce qu'en pensent les
téléspectateurs juste déjà karl olive
on va on va écouter ce qu'ils disent et
après je voudrais que vous leur répondez
alors ce qu'ils disent oui
géraldine maillet ou dit oui bah oui
parce qu'on fait ça n'a jamais été
tentée et donc c'est bien d'essayer
parce qu'effectivement aujourd'hui à
unia pour moi j'ai l'impression qu'à une
sorte de jeunesse tado si violent alors
ils sont arrêtés
il reste deux jours au poste et puis
après ressort et revient dans la cité
comme des caïds comme des héros alors ça
concerne une minorité
moi je mangerai quoi si on a une
cinquantaine après oui mais oui
j'aimerais qu'on arrête de dire
hégémonie après ce que j'en ai marre
qu'on dit jeunes de city des jeunes de
scei ici je n'ai la suite est encore
plus jour actifs parce que mais c'est
parce que je parlais de du canada s'est
délité ne sont pas consultées nord mais
voilà allez aussi à poissy strong
willard on voit aussi parce qu'il ya le
maire de poissy qui ici il s'agit de
une cinquante je crois une cinquantaine
des mineurs qui vont caillassé les
commissariats qu'ils vont mettre le feu
à des à des locaux associatifs donc
c'est très précis donc je parle de ce
cas là en particulier sans stigmatiser
moi je trouve ça bien de responsabiliser
les parents
en plus c'est une main tendue aux
parents c'est à dire que le maire décide
de éventuellement suspendre certaines
aides pour les loisirs de papa les
allocations familiales est pas la
comptine parce que ça c'est vital et ça
c'est très important et certaines
bourses donc moi je trouve ça très bien
parce que justement il faut
responsabiliser les parents
il faut arrêter enfin les parents ne
doivent pas être démissionnaire même si
c'est très difficile d'être parents et
parfois ils perdent complètement le fil
et moi je trouve que c'est très bien
j'ai justement d'essayer de renouer le
dialogue et je trouve que c'est une
bonne une bonne décision je voudrais un
an gilles verdez cette décision schirmer
karl olive est absurde et elle est
scandaleuse parce que imaginer le frère
le frère d'un jeune délinquant c'est sa
famille qui va être stigmatisé vous
allez briser des familles entières et
d'autre part si les skis c'est lé débat
là dessus vous tapez sur les familles
pauvres parce que ce sont hélas les
familles pauvres qui ont des allocations
d'accord vous tapez sur elle mais je
vous signale qu'il ya plein d'enfants de
familles riches qui sont délinquants
cris font des bêtises et eux ils sont
exemptés par votre décision
donc c'est une manière d' encore une
fois à taper sur des familles qui font
tout ce qu'ils soient tout ce qui est en
leur pouvoir et ses mails et les
familles qui ont des enfants délinquants
ils sont désespérés et délais toutes
faites les aider par les travailleurs
sociaux que 90 de leur taper dessus
monsieur le maire je vous dis tu as à
carlo il se trouve tout d'abord je veux
dire que fois ci est une très belle
ville
c'est la ville où je suis né avec une
famille nombreuse ont été mises dans les
quartiers populaires monsieur verdez et
j'y ai grandi avec une très belle mixité
sociale
et justement les aides communales
facultative que nous donnons à l'endroit
des familles et des parents et quelle
qu'elle soit je vous rejoins sans aucune
exclusive par rapport aux quartiers
populaires c'est des aides pour
permettre aux enfants de pouvoir aller
dans des clubs de sport dans des clubs
culturels en leur permettant d'avoir 30
euros donc c'est du pouvoir d'achat
justement par rapport à ces familles
c'est également des êtres vous le disiez
cyril hanouna sur des bourses entre 100
et 400 euros par mois ce qui n'est pas
rien qu'est-ce qui se passe
moi je crois à la réciprocité entre les
droits et les devoirs qu'on ait un
contrat
mais en gagnant très honnêtement il ya
quelques mois on retrouve à 4 heures du
matin un jeune de 14 ans qui vient
caillassé des abribus à 14 ans on est en
pleine nuit en train de casser des
abribus et forêts que je lui donne une
médaille d'honneur de la ville de poissy
c'est parce qu'on fait après si tout le
monde connaît les règles et ça se passe
très bien
y compris dans les quartiers populaires
pourquoi j'ai pris cette décision avec
mes collègues à la très grande majorité
36 sur 39 c'est que depuis six mois on
constate qu'on a une recrudescence de la
délinquance mineure entre 12 et 17 ans
et je pense qu'ils ont considéré qu'il
faut sensibiliser les parents la fête
voilà alors c'est pas les sensibiliser
de façon conjoncturelle depuis six mois
ce depuis des années qu'on travaille
avec avec les parents et main dans la
main et ça se passe très bien mais moi
il est hors de question que j'envoie un
message à l'immense majorité de la
population qui a un comportement
exemplaire pour 5%
vous le disiez à peu près une
cinquantaine de jeunes qui viennent
pourrir le quotidien de nos administrés
et je veux être très vigilants par
rapport à cela
ce n'est pas un chèque en blanc alors
voilà on va bien le maire de valence
aussi un qu'il a fait faire fin décembre
le maire les républicains balance
nicolas d'aragon qui avait fait part en
est lui aussi avait été motivée par des
actes de violence urbaine il avait
expliqué notamment chez jean marc
morandini
j'aimerais qu'on ait des oui tout de
suite
on passa dernières parties après gallo
ana carril c'est parti très bon oui je
suis étonné que très bon méchoui matches
cette année c'est gégé et je suis blessé
moi j'ai vécu 28 ans cité entre la cité
d'orgemont les mourinoux le luth les
fossés gens moi j'ai grandi là dedans
pendant 28 ans quand j'ai pu partir je
suis parti parce que dès qu'une banque
m'a prêté de l'argent je voulais pas ce
que j'ai vécu moi pour mes enfants et à
un moment donné là où je dis qu'il faut
responsabiliser les parents
c'est que c'est en parents en premier
d'éduquer leurs enfants c'est pas à la
république et à l'état à la république
et l'état ne peut pas tout faire donc un
moment donné qu est ce qui se passe
celui qui peut se marrer de la cité il
se barre est celui qui peut pas se
barrer il reste gangréné et il ya plus
de mixité et on reste dans un ghetto et
restent enfermés les anelka les homards
les layènes jamais de bulls ils sont
partis d'autres appels sont pas restés
dès qu'ils ont pu ce bar et son bar et
du coup tu t'enfermes dans une mixité
ça c'est mon premier point pourquoi je
veux que les parents soient peut-être
pas sanctionné mais reste
saby lisez le deuxième point là vous
vous trompez monsieur karl olive c'est
que vous sanctionnez quelque chose à mon
goût quelle saison c'est bon ça marche
c'est mon avis c'est par là qu'il faut
sanctionner parce que vous sanctionner
en oz municipal c'est à dire par le
biais du sport quelqu'un qui est déjà à
rejeter pas seulement pas seulement mais
s'il n'ose poirier beaucoup la bourse et
le sport quelqu'un qui est déjà rejeté
quinquas qui est mal à l'aise on lui dit
qu'il va pas faire du sport avec ses
copains vous vous sentez qu'il va pas
être encore plus rejetée bien sûr qu'il
va être encore plus rejetés et comment
vous faites respecter ça parce que moi
je me met dans la position que j'ai dit
pote à moi qui vont au sport et parce
que j'ai fait une connerie dans un arrêt
de bus
on me dit il rappe en sport ben moi je
peux le jurer sur la tête de la mer que
j'irai quand même dans ce gymnase qui va
m'interdire de rentrer dans le gymnase
les agents municipaux que vous allez en
fait m comme en termes de cow boy
c'est eux qui vont devoir encore mettre
un problème sur le problème vous allez
faire venir la police dans le gymnase
s'affairent encore des débris histoire
parce que la police devra intervenir à
l'olive parce qu'un jeune ait pas
rentrer dans le gymnase ce que vous
pouvez répondre par le biais du sport
c'est le laisser le réputé bon vous
connaissez le football vous connaissez
un cas règles du jeu les règles du jeu
quand on les connaît il faut qu'on soit
dans un contrat gagnant gagnant
c'est qu'on tournait pas dans le jeu on
est en dehors du jeu quel message on
envoie l'immense majorité de cette
population tient que je vais aller vers
bizet verbaliser avec les policiers
municipaux de main sur du stationnement
ils vont me dire mais arrêtez de jouer
de la trompette vous êtes incapable de
pouvoir surveiller ces jeunes à qui vous
offrez vous offrez et tant mieux parce
qu'on l'assument maskass ça se passe
très bien on offre des aides qui sont
facultatives mais encore une fois ce
n'est pas un chèque en blanc et moi je
veux pas rester les bras croisés avez
raison je vous rejoins c'est qu'on doit
être accompagnée par l'état on doit être
accompagnée par les bailleurs pourquoi
les bailleurs ne prennent pas leurs
responsabilités quand il ya des
déflagrations dans les dents les dans
les cages commune sur les vitres il
devrait retenir aussi quelque chose à la
source dans l'eure dans leur loyer ils
ne le font pas vous savez pourquoi parce
qu'il ya des choses en politique qui se
greffent pas il faut un peu de courage
par rapport à cela
je note que depuis ce matin à un nombre
une dizaine de maires de toute la france
m'ont appelé pour justement avoir la
délibération que nous avons bien il y en
a beaucoup qui vont suivre
a je pense qu'on en a beaucoup qui vont
suivre et puis quand je regarde les
sondages que vous avez pu effectuer
depuis on va voir sa masse dans cette
instance je peux vous dire que sur 10
admis
responsabiliser si vous responsabiliser
pas les parents je vous le dis on est
dans un ghetto il faut absolument sortir
mais s'il est justement un droit hier de
voir retirer la vie enfin médias s'est
faite sous peu
nicolas pernikoff apprendrait attendez
il ya juste un truc alors c'est bien ce
que tu viens dire bon tu propose pas de
solution il est dans l'action moi je
connais très bien
poissy-saint-germain-en-laye n'y a pas
de police elle n'a pas bougé de ces
coiffes et attendait a pas de police
c'est eux qui ont mis 50 police
municipale sur le secteur pour faire
revenir la police il ya 30% de
cambriolages en moins depuis trois ans
un moment donné les parents ils doivent
bien être responsabilisés on en parle
chaque fois comment veux tu es moi c'est
le prix du sandwich le sport véhicule
des valeurs mais on n'est pas là pour
demander des solutions non mais là pour
rire et ça marche
s'il vous plaît kelly à pondaurat des
questions sur le groupe surprend la
question c'est les parents et ce qu'on
doit les sanctionner moi je trouve ça
juste honteux de sera sanctionné départ
oui vraiment ça alors vraie question on
parle des parents là dessus moi je
trouve ça honteux de devoir sanctionner
des parents pourquoi parce qu'on va pas
se mentir on n'a pas des hypocrites on
sait très bien que la plupart de la
délinquance est bien des quartiers
sensibles des cités et s'est désolé
parce que beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
itunes alors si on part de ça moi c'est
mon avis d'accord si on part de ça parce
que il est donc tu dis ça mais tu as des
chiffres et à coire où aller on s'en
fout on s'en fout il a battu mais si je
pars sur sa america tueur et bien sûr
c'est ce qu'on irait plutôt
naturellement dans tous les cas si je
pars de ce problème là moi ce que je dis
c'est que c'est honteux de s'en prendre
à des parents pourquoi pas parce qu'à un
moment donné les parents ils sont
débordés ils n'en peuvent plus ils ont
pas choisi d'habiter dans cet endroit là
ils n'ont pas choisi leur vie ils n'ont
pas le choix ils sont débordés ils ont
beaucoup d'enfants pour beaucoup faut
pas se mentir les rencontres ayant
besoin rencontre il va l'entraîner on
parle chez ma question c'est est-ce que
ton jeu dont je dis non sanctionne pas
des parents quand il n'a pas assez de
police qui sont là pour mesurer aussi
certains délinquants quand la police
sont devenus des endroits comme ça cette
question des bas mais on remet des
choses alors oui je réponde à ça si on
veut faire vraiment des vrais les choses
se doit eh ben on éclate les cités on
relance les gens comme moi si l'aréna o2
propos des pâtes solution poser des
questions alors paradoxalement je suis
d'accord avec eux aussi avec votre
consultant juste pour dire que ça me
permet de retisser le juriste raconte
justement ça me permet de retisser le
lien kenny avec avec justement les
familles qu'on a perdu et qui parfois
refuse l'accompagnement et je suis
d'accord avec l'état qui nous dit faites
tomber les tours et les bars ok mais ne
nous imposez pas s'il vous plaît
derrière des populations qui sont
fragiles et qui ne veut pas ils ne
veulent pas venir habiter ici chez des
familles qui sont là depuis 40 ans
parfaitement intégrée qui elle-même
veulent partir parce qu'elle n'en
peuvent plus mais moi je ne veux pas
encore une fois resté les bras croisés
c'est mes administrés n'ont plus que
j'ai la faiblesse de penser de les
connaître
j'y suis né j'y ai grandi j'ai du sang
de la ville de poissy qui coule dans mes
veines
j'aime cette ville je ne veux pas que ça
parte en sucette alors quand je vois que
c'est à dire qu'on apprendra moi je dis
non parce que c'est la porte ouverte à
l'orapa plein de sanctions alors on est
bien mais c'est vrai on commence par le
sport puis après ça veut dire pourquoi
ne pas dire bah écoutez si vous aussi
vos enfants son passage dans les rues on
va sur bosses supprimer les aides pour
le logement et est allé moi c'est ça qui
me fait peur c'est que si on commence
comme ça effectivement
moi je ne pense pas qu'on doit sur
effectivement sanctionner les parents
parce qu'effectivement souvent il ya
plusieurs frères et soeurs déjà et si on
commence comme ça je dis alors c'est la
question la question la question
résultat vous mets ta pour
responsabiliser mais pas la question
mais les passages sur ce bordeaux
chennai c'est pas la question
non combien de temps après le relais
parce que je pense que vous leur parlez
si on s'en fout on est sur la sanction
donc sur madame morini bosc
il a reconnu que les mariés parce que
j'adore rtl il se trouve
nous avons un sautoir un sens des dents
1 dans un stade à poissy le jeune qui a
fait ça a été pris en flagrant délit par
les caméras de vidéo protection comme le
disait monsieur pernikoff tout à l'heure
il se trouve que cet enfant était le
papa d'un agent parfaitement intégrés
j'ai pris le papa vie qu'est ce qu'on
fait qu'est ce qu'on fait tu payes je
paye que tu mets ton ton enfant devant
ses responsabilités et ses skis
esquisses et c'est ce qui s'est passé
avec l'enfant dans le bureau on n'a plus
du tout était ennuyé c'est aussi un
électrochoc qu'il faut envoyer des
masses mais encore une fois qu'est ce
que j'en vois comme message à l'immense
partie de ma population qui est juste
exceptionnelle
monsieur carlo nîmes c'est juste si je
peux me permettre guillaume genton qu'on
avance des raisons la question qui se
pose c'est celle de la sanction des
parents mais la chose que monsieur le
maire il met en place une sens une
sanction qui est light parce qu'encore
une fois en main de bourse tertiaire ce
sont des bourses scolaires qui sont
uniquement pour les élèves et non idéal
voilà les aides vitales victoire voilà
les allocations familiales et c'est
comme ça sont conservés donc monsieur le
maire a raison on n'a pas félicité un
jeune qui a cassé des abri bus qui a
agressé des policiers les entière bravo
voilà une bourse scolaire qui encore une
fois tertiaire donc sanctionner les
parents et qui fait les vivres à des
familles qui sont dans le besoin
évidemment que c'est que c'est mal
maintenant envoyer un signal pour juste
dire en fait qu'une agression c'est mal
je trouve ça normal
à ce moment avec mon exemple juste un
exemple monsieur le maire vous avons
touche pas aux allocations familiales
on touche pas à ce qui est vital vous
toucher au sport 30 euros par sicard
entend par là je prends un exemple pour
moi si j'étais rentré un jour j'ai cassé
un abribus et vous allez dire à mon père
mais je t'envie fond c'est que je vais
t'en lever les 30 euros 2,2 pour aller
au sport baril va me regarde droit dans
les yeux
maintenant tu te démerdes pas les faire
du sport ça changera pas d'éducation il
fera rien mon père qui me laissera dans
la rue à 3 heures du matin mais dira
c'est bien fait pour ta gueule
maintenant tu peux plus aller au sport
mais moines gymnase
je rentre quand même par la porte des
poubelles parce que je l'avais moi même
dans les concessions moi je rentrais
chapelle la maréchaussée
un sujet sérieux parce qu'il laissait à
la chance et ça je suis d'accord avec
vous mais sa fondation sa bise et les
familles oui mais là mais ça fonctionne
simplement vous le dites parce qu'il
faut que les règles soient connus de
tout et de tous savent et ils sont très
contents ces jeunes les familles sont
très contents de bénéficier de ces aides
et pas seulement sur d'autres dead dead
par exemple pour le permis de conduire
pour passer le bafa
tout le monde est content mais enfin
dans la vie il ya des droits et des
devoirs entièrement d'accord moi je veux
bien qu'on profite du système et je
l'assumé je suis très heureux ça remet
enfin c'est quand même des deniers
publics
jean-pierre moi ici à poissy
actuellement c'est la scène qui est en
crue 1 c'est pas les données publiques
alors juste mais karlovic est vrai qu on
écoute un des porte parole du
gouvernement bernard morel a son mot à
dire oui maintenant il est divers droite
oui mais justement non moi je dois vite
savoir et raisonnée moi je trouve que
vous avez raison évidemment il faut
responsabiliser il veut lécher le cul de
toulouse la raison j'ai dit oui depuis
le début il faut responsabiliser les
parents et s'il faut taper au
portefeuille bien il faut le faire c'est
comme ça que certaines personnes
comprennent
j'aimerais voir ce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs l'échec oui regardez
vous croyez m'en doutais qu'il nous
plaît on ne vous a pas demandé de
détente c'est vrai que ça carlo l'ifri
qui commandent s'il vous plaît on n'a
pas besoin de commentateurs on a
quelqu'un ici directement dévoile à ses
nuits concerne je vais je vais pas on va
pas inventé la machine à courber de vote
j'en suis juste ravi on va pas s'en fait
décent féliciter et au delà de ça donc
simplement c'est juste quelque chose de
cohérent
moi je me rassure que l'ensemble de mes
administrés incroyable et mesdames
messieurs pardon de le dire
l'ensemble des français aujourd'hui il
ya quelque chose qui nous par la figure
c'est que ça va péter dans nos quartiers
populaires des histoires exactement
et si on n'aime pas ces gens exactions
ne les respectent pas alors on va le
prendre pleine figure et il faut les
respecter ne faut pas les stigmatiser
alors c'est ce qu'on fait à peu aussi en
revanche aucun état d'âme pour celles et
ceux qui pourrissent la vie des
administrés au quotidien c'est une
petite minorité mais moi je ne laisse
pas les bras croisés
pour